The next section in each pattern description talks about implementation.
The design pattern that we've, understood so
far has to do with the design of a solution.
Not necessarily It's implementation.
Implementation means translating that design into some code.
Okay?
Doing that often means that there are choices arise.
And it's important to understand the implication of the those choices.
The implementation section of a design pattern description lays out
those implementation issues, and alternative ways of addressing them.
For the Composite pattern, here are some of the issues that arise.
We know that in the pattern so far, we have references from parents to children.
An issue that you might wish to include, or a feature you might wish to
include is, do you have pointers from children back to parents.
Once you do this, of course, referential integrity problems might arise.
Another issue is whether we would allow multiple parents to refer to
the same children.
Imagine that you have separate hierarchies in
which the leaf elements are shared.
This, of course, can be powerful if you wish to do it because it
reduces the overall number of objects that you have.
But it might also increase your code complexity if you were to do that.
Similar to the situation where we just described in which moving the add
operation up in the hierarchy has the benefit of making the uni-,
the interface more uniform.
However, it might lead to having unnatural operations at
too high a level in the hierarchy.
Similarly placing the list of children up one level,
also would mean that somehow now leafs at children.
Now, the issue is what data structure should you use to keep the list of
children, their hash tables, their arrays, link, lesson, so on.
Finally is the question of whether, when you delete a composite,
do you also delete its children?